heute entscheidet der Bundestag über das
Infektionsschutzgesetz und damit über
weitreichende corona-maßnahmen die uns
alle betreffen in diesem Herbst und im
Winter darunter auch eine mögliche
maskenpflicht für Schüler ab Klasse 5
aber es gibt Widerspruch ausgerechnet
von einem der offiziellen Corona Berater
der Regierung der Vorsitzende der Ärzte
des öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienstes
ließen erteilt der Bundesregierung eine
Lektion die schülermasken seien bei den
aktuellen corona-varianten nicht nötig
corona-klatsche also für die Ampel mal
wieder
so was kommt jetzt auf uns zu wir reden
mit Bild
politikredakteurin Lydia Rosenfeld was
kommt da genau auf uns zu jetzt also
gerade was die schülermasken angeht das
wird noch sehr spannend
Herr Niessen hat ja gesagt der übrigens
auch im corona-rat der Bundesregierung
sitzt also quasi der eigene
kanzleramtsberater hat der Richtung
Politik gesagt bei den aktuellen
Varianten brauchen wir keine
maskenpflicht für Schüler und das zeigt
ja dass das da schon längst eine
Umdenken stattgefunden hat das auch in
der Politik sich mal durchsetzen sollte
denn die Immunität bei Kindern ist
vermutlich sehr sehr sehr hoch eine
immunitätsstudie hat ja sogar schon im
Frühjahr ergeben vom
Robert-Koch-Institut das über 500 über
92 Prozent der Bevölkerung eine
grundimmunität haben das heißt sie sind
entweder genesen oder geimpft oder
beides und wenn man sich mal anschaut
wie viele Menschen über den Sommer hin
Corona hatten ja kann man sich ja
ausrechnen dass es nur noch ein ganz
ganz kleiner Teil ist der gar keine
Grund genugisierung hat und damit keinen
Schutz vor schweren Verläufen die es bei
umicron ja sowieso auch nur noch
seltener gibt insofern wird sich vieles
von dem was was in diesem
Instrumentenkasten wie es ja immer so
beschönigend gesagt wird drin steckt
hoffentlich in diesem Winter sowieso von
selbst erledigen darunter ganz bestimmt
die maskenpflicht für Kinder denn wie
man das erklären möchte dass man den
Kindern so etwas noch zumutet das ist
meine meines Erachtens gar nicht mehr
erklärbar aktueller Widerspruch auch das
Masken im Flugzeug abgeschafft werden
sollen aber in der Bahn müssen sie noch
getragen werden wie erklärst du dir das
macht das Sinn also die Regierung
erklärt das damit dass die Belüftung in
den Flugzeugen so gut ist die absaugluft
da wird sozusagen die verbrauchte Luft
abgesaugt dann super gefiltert mit
virenfiltern und dann wieder
reingeblasen und da fragt man sich schon
ja warum haben wir denn dann so lange
überhaupt maskenpflicht im Flugzeug
gehabt die auf europäischer Ebene wird
das schon seit Sommer nicht mehr
empfohlen aber gut wir sind in
Deutschland immer ein bisschen langsamer
das ist jetzt abgeschafft in Zügen
bleibt das aber noch weil da angeblich
die
Voraussetzungen anderes sind zur so
erklärt das zumindest die Ampel die
Frage ist aber dieser Paradigmenwechsel
den man jetzt im Flugzeug gemacht hat
hin zu mehr Eigenverantwortung mehr ich
entscheide will ich mich schützen oder
habe ich sozusagen das Gefühl ich bin
jetzt nicht mehr gefährdet ich brauche
jetzt auch den Mundschutz nicht mehr
kann ich so eine Entscheidung nicht auch
im Zug für mich treffen ja also wann
hört die Regierung auf mir exakt
vorzuschreiben wann ich die Maske
aufsetze und wann wieder ab insofern
wird früher oder später diese das Ende
der maskenpflicht auch im Zug kommen
müssen so wie es heute beschlossen wird
kommt das erst an Ostern man macht also
ein Datum eine sozusagen eine Maßnahme
von einem Datum abhängig und nicht davon
wie die Pandemie verläuft das ist schon
mal sehr merkwürdig und die Frage ist ob
da nicht vorher auch noch geklagt wird
z.B in Fernbussen Fernbusse haben ganz
ähnliche Voraussetzungen wie Flugzeuge
da gilt die maskenpflicht aber weiterhin
also da durch das Ende der maskenpflicht
in Flugzeugen wird sich mehr und mehr
die Frage stellen ob es in anderen
Bereichen überhaupt noch gerechtfertigt
also ein Ende der maskenpflicht im Zug
muss kommen sagt Bild politikredakteurin
Lydia Rosenfelder vielen vielen Dank
dass Sie heute bei uns warst
[Musik]